i don't know acting
i'm sorry man you're there 16 hour days
and i don't think that's as satisfying
no matter who you are and also it's so
fake
they're
but also the trap is having a persona i
showed up in new york and i decided to
start wearing kangal hats backwards they
look good on me i decided i'm i'm gonna
be a good looking actor because i saw
some actor do it
it's too busy i'm not a fedora no a
beret is this is this is the worst if
you wear a [ __ ] beret i'm gonna throw
a french braid i'm throwing you in a
flying headlock even if you're brock
lesnar if you have a beret and a
cigarette holder like hunter s thompson
well now i kind of like you if you're a
dandy and you have an ear trumpet and a
cigarette holder now i like you i have a
hard time with dudes who wear vests
me too i do want though i do want to
dress like a like a like a cuban
gentleman at the end of the day i want
to wear linen suits
and i want to smoke fine cigars there is
or a pipe there is part of me i like how
often do you smoke cigars never ever
ever so
what's stopping you i don't know just
store it on the street i just thought i
should get some cigars this is a joint
bro oh jesus a blunt
yeah i like that
yeah it's tobacco on the outside
really this is the [ __ ] that crashed the
tesla stock brought it down
that'll hurt my lungs man is it mostly
weed oh yeah the inside's weed
you get a little little head rush from
the tobacco
and then you get a little
little a little uh
life i'm such a lightweight life inside
the brain because of the
the marijuana there we go
if we only had some wine it would be
perfect pink she'll break out some fine
whiskey hey we don't have any glasses
yeah we'll be all right
we could just drink out of the glass
like like gentlemen at the bottom
yeah we have cups you have to get out of
here no all right i never have to
keep talking man people say oh sorry i'm
here
[Music]